a bank building gone rogue a music
legend cameo ghost sharks unexpected
floods and a full orchestra shockingly
all of these were involved in bringing
the fifth pirates of the caribbean movie
to the screen
and today we are filming parts of the
caribbean
dead men tell no tales
follow me hi is your bank running well
you better go catch it
what fun is cgi when you've got a team
that can put together a production like
this we've got a tractor at the core of
that bank which was built by the art
department and of course this stampede
of horses oh yeah that bank tractor
driver couldn't see where he was going
coordination within all the departments
was key here did we mention this was at
the top of filming off to the race as we
go
everybody clear cause the wall is coming
down
[Music]
yeah we were serious
not a shortcut was taken to pull off
stunts of this magnitude these sets
managed to cause chaos in more ways than
one though
help me
step aside baby shark it's time for
ghost sharks how broken you can make
something look and still keep it
threatening we've never really thought
about it but the pirates team was hard
at work building fully realized versions
of the sharks and then going in
digitally to really ghostify them we're
talking broken jaws flies slime the goal
was for these sharks to look really
menacing now if we were to run into
these in the wild we'd definitely run
the other way so mission accomplished
team
chuck
hey salazar need some moisturizer they
look like they've been blown up the idea
of cracked earth quickly inspired
salazar and his cruise look one that
meant a whole lot of time was being
spent in the makeup chair this is all
prosthetics
we're talking three three and a half
hours every single time it took me a
little while to adjust to the time frame
patience was key though not everyone had
the full treatment done this is all done
with stencils and transfers there aren't
enough hours in a day to do it all how
much of his head is missing exactly and
is he okay they were bringing this idea
of the
face with a hole in it
which i it was hard for me to imagine
while he did have incredible prosthetics
the salazar actor still got the cgi
treatment to make so much of his skull
go bye-bye it was either cracked earth
makeup or blue for javier perfect for
achieving that uh
let's call it a ghostly aesthetic
new director new dop new cast members
it's been a very rewarding one change
can be tough but bringing in new
directors was welcomed with open arms
directors are very young and very
energetic they move the camera a lot
they use a lot of drones bringing in a
new perspective for the fifth film in
the franchise turned out to be a pretty
special experience
they managed to brilliantly keep within
the pirate genre while bringing a bit of
a different look to the screen i felt it
was like it's a real moment every day on
this on this shoot is that dirt or
makeup or both becoming gibbs was a far
from glamorous process tan sunburn and
then
muck
some rubbish shirt but it was definitely
creative since he had to get a kind of
grimy dirty look why waste fancy makeup
when you can go with the best source of
all we get a little mud from the car
park
and we rub it in like that see
and even that could be too fancy at
times and we're rationing the mud from
the car park this morning get me some
more mud from the car park something
looks different
but the same he really isn't gibbs
without the signature mutton chops which
happened to have been grown by kevin
mcnally himself for the first four
movies but for dead men tell no tales i
have time to grow them this time the
best part about prosthetic mutton chops
they didn't have as much gray hair as
mcnally really does
is gunk ever really convenient
the salazar actor was initially told the
gunk he was going to use would taste
like chocolate but the reality wasn't so
sweet have the air dove right in though
they were supposed to put it on the
teeth i said give me that so i drunk it
but then it all came pouring out of his
mouth again disgust was a real strong
vibe that day better watch out where
you're going or you'll land somewhere
you shouldn't that was not comfortable
at all it was early days in the filming
process and one of this pair's first
scenes together and kaya made a bit of a
misstep the director thought it would be
funny to have her step on her co-star's
crotch but not for real of course
unfortunately they missed the mark on
this one i accidentally stood a new
crotch
and a final sprint to the finish line it
had been such a tough shoot and so long
and everyone's so tired no better way to
wrap up than shooting with high stakes
we had a scene where
we could only do it once this scene
turned out to be one of the best ways to
finish the experience in a setting that
was more like a family vacation than a
movie set it's a good thing everything
went off without a hitch since that
beach couldn't be reset so easily after
the cast ran through like we're running
towards the finish line they didn't have
to be in the sea to be underwater we
have a sequence under the sea yes in
around two or three months the crew
built this incredible environment on dry
land we were tasked with the
job of trying to create an underwater
environment every single detail we see
was built from scratch from the coral to
the creatures to the sea floor a lot of
coral of texture
very very wet having such a detailed and
rich environment made it very easy for
the actors to feel like they really were
underwater are we under water or is it
just special effects two weeks of that
you get a little
cuckoo but uh
it looks good in the movie yeah no
kidding we'd be asking that if we saw
lights and shadows that so convincingly
made it feel like we were in the bottom
of the sea too we ended up with a very
simple
system of just old-fashioned water
tricks
a giant lighting rig and small pools of
water that were hung up along the
ceiling and connected with other lights
that could be manipulated while shooting
made all of this possible who needs cg
when you've got blinking lights and
perfectly rippled water
number 14. land hoe
not just yet though there is some pirate
business to take care of of course there
were many days on set spent in the water
both on huge rigs and smaller dinghies
many of which were made just for the
movie by the way once you get into the
pirates world anything can happen the
view is bliss but getting changed out at
sea is hardly comfortable a price worth
paying though for a movie like this
sometimes it's easy as walking
it looks epic to film but take after
take of continuously being wet in mocap
suits no less well it doesn't make for
the easiest day on set
walking in this case not so chill but of
course the pirates team makes it work
surprisingly there were no yellow
submarines on set enough said he's one
of the greatest musicians songwriters
performers paul mccartney happens to be
a close pal of johnny depps and came on
board as a favor even though he was
surprised to be asked at all
it's well made
by the looks of depp's delighted face
mccartney delivered
oh maggie maggie may they have taken
their way
yeah i'm loving him they look good but
they are far from practical kaya
scotlario was whipping out stunts on set
all while wearing 17 layers including a
tight corset i'm very much a jeans and
t-shirt girl so i was quite nervous
about all of that there were also plenty
of heels on set but not just for the
women take note brenton thwaites was
sporting them in not so ideal conditions
i found the high heels on the boats to
be pretty challenging toss those heels
overboard
sorry we're here for the pirates of the
caribbean content
whoa yep this is it no solo acoustic
guitar tracks here dead men tell no
tales went all out recording the
orchestrations and incidental music live
for the film it really does take a
village and this one can certainly play
listen to that string section
and next up we'll be serenaded by jack
sparrow himself when he wasn't busy jack
sparrowing johnny depp could be found
tucked away spending some quality time
with his guitar it's nice to see that
kind of quiet side to him i think
between depp and that orchestra this
team was set for tunes how many ships
does it take to make a pirates of the
caribbean movie for dead men tell no
tales there were a whopping 13 ships
built including one that measured a
massive hundred and sixty feet long
and these were no basic boats see how
every detail tiny detail of the of the
construction of the set is so well taken
care of period speak is tricky business
kevin mcnally has been doing the pirates
gig from the very beginning and if
something didn't sound right he was
gonna know it his accurate year came in
very handy for kaia she was still
learning the ropes we were discussing in
line i think i say okay and he pulled up
and he said nope that is not
historically accurate sticklers for
detail make pirates of the caribbean the
legendary franchise it is
some takes may have been ruined but it
doesn't mean they weren't fun when takes
went sour it wasn't necessarily because
an actor messed up in this case it's
because this pirate was a bit too good
at his job well actually he didn't the
actors around him did like i like myself
at least they all got a good laugh
number 23
no matter which costume it was you can
be sure it was detailed to the max
there's two different costumes there's a
clean version and then this one is what
we call a ghosted version from the fine
silver embroidery to the individually
attached buttons the character in this
costume speaks volumes
number 24 the production schedule got
thrown for a loop because the one and
only jack sparrow was so often late it
was such a problem that the team
actually had a production assistant
literally staking outside of depp's
house in a car waiting to see when the
actor woke up just so the production
could get moving filming was then
further delayed by an offset hand injury
that put depp out of commission where so
much magic happened working on
whitsunday islands is particularly
special because they happen to be sacred
lands before the crew began filming
representatives from the yangaro people
performed a traditional smoking ceremony
to bring good spirits to the team and
production the movie making marathon is
exhausting but that's what it takes to
bring an epic film to the screen which
set would you have wanted to visit